make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so you guys are got to be with me
for a second it might be a little bit
echoey in here and I'll try my best to
reduce it but I'm actually working on my
sound recording space at the moment so
we got to make do but we are covering
powers of X those you guys who follow me
on Twitter you guys know that I was
taking a break for this week but I'm
doing powers of X because I love house
of powers of X now we're house of X
covers the tenth life of Mora McTaggart
basically powers of X covers a tin like
number Liat in your window a covers
three different time periods right so
the point at which the x-men were being
formed or at least when Xavier was
trying to bring the team together before
it really officially formed and then the
second era is basically the modern day
and then the third era is in the future
now one thing we've never actually done
here is we haven't actually established
a chronological time period of when this
takes place right I mean for the sake of
the story Hickman is just using a
general period of time like between this
point and this point is basically when
everything takes place that way he's not
really forced to narrow things down and
force it into a chronological period
because then it would all kind of go to
pieces later on down the line Marvel
also kind of makes an editorial mandate
as far as I'm aware you can't really
ascribe dates to comics otherwise it
actually puts a solidified date on them
whereas you can simply just say it takes
place somewhere maybe around the modern
day who knows I just kind of call it a
day where does what they really do now
Charles Xavier served in the Korean War
which lasted loosely between 1950 and
1953 right I mean it's give or take you
know a few months here and there in
terms of the beginning in the end but we
can usually say it at some point in 1953
is basically when it came to an end and
then from there we basically have what's
around a maybe an 11-year window not
really an 11 year window probably a a
nine year eight or nine year window
between the time the Korean War ended
and the time Xavier started the x-men
now before Hickman started writing the
writing the comics as they exist now the
explanation of the Marvel gave us in
terms of why Xavier started the x-men in
the first place was because of the fact
that he met Amahl Farouk he met the
Shadow King and it was first
introduction into a mutant that was
literally just malevolent right it was
just an evil entity that existed out
there and didn't want to do anything but
inflict harm on people and realizing
that that was you know that it would
make no sense to simply assume it was
the only one and drawing the logical
conclusion that there's other mutants
out there that would try to pursue the
same goal right world domination or just
inflicting harm or whatever
Xavier launched the x-men and so what
we're looking at here is some time
during this eight year window between
1953-54
running all the way up to around 1961-62
so we've obviously around nine years uh
when the x1 were basically introduced in
Marvel Comics Wray released when the
team was officially formed right because
when the comic first picked up the team
had already been formed so we can we can
kind of say somewhere along those lines
and this eight-year window is when all
this takes place but what this does you
know where it says x-men 0x been year
one ah this basically picks up with him
going to visit bar-sinister
now again this is hickman referencing
his own work bar-sinister was given to
us as part of seeker Wars right when you
had like a battle world and you had the
the realm where sinister hung out his
base of operations more or less it was
called bar-sinister so it's kind of cool
to see because what you also get here
are all these different versions of
sinister himself now this is something
Jonathan Hickman does not explain those
of you guys who read secret Wars and who
read Avengers New Avengers can harken
back to this but the only real
conclusion we can draw from this is that
either these are clones as sinister made
of himself or they're the alternate
reality counterparts who have just been
here ever since now you have these
different versions of himself and then
you have the actual Nathaniel Essex who
seems to be the one sitting here this is
kind of a big moment here and this is
kind of a big thing because what Hickman
does is change up pretty much everything
we know about Nathaniel Essex and he
says he has a mutant gene this is wholly
new territory this is Jonathan Hickman
shifting things up entirely but for
sinister himself a little bit of
backstory here and and you guys will
find a link in the description for mr.
sinister explained which again as part
of our x-men playlist or x-men
encyclopedia to basically sum this up
the sinister used to be called a guy
named Nathaniel Essex and the idea was
that he would he was obsessed with
genealogy right he was obsessed with the
idea that somewhere along the line that
humans were going to give way to people
with abilities right so it was basically
the concept of mutants but not really
knowing what it was and where someone
just a theory that he had but because of
the fact of the villain apocalypse
didn't really even know what he was and
then overheard the theories of sinister
and then was basically told you're a
mutant right you the next stage in human
evolution in response the question was
asked do you want to be able to do this
kind of stuff forever and when the
answer was yes then you ended up having
apocalypse who uses technology to
transform Nathaniel Essex into mr.
sinister right so up until this point
this particular comic right now the form
and function of Sinister's powers is
that they were bestowed on him by
external means by you know apocalypse
using celestial technology to modify the
genes and Nathaniel Essex what Hickman
is doing here is saying no that
basically either he's gonna reconcile
the two and say that what apocalypse did
was
wake up the mutant gene of a Nathaniel
Essex or he's gonna come back and he's
gonna say that never happened but then
basically meeting with sinister is
interesting here because Xavier shows up
and he basically says we know that what
you're doing right now it's going
through and cataloging the world's DNA
that's what sinister does he looks at
the entire world's population and says
who's a particular interest here
basically it's it's Professor X and
Magneto simply saying we know that you
catalog mutant genes and even just human
genes to a degree we know that you're a
collector these are things that are of
interest to you so what we want to do
here is we want to work with you we
basically want to bring you the entire
catalogue of the mutant genealogy as we
discover it you will be the one who will
who will catalog it you'll hold on to it
you'll examine it you can do whatever
you want with it just don't destroy the
genes and don't you know do anything
like nefarious you don't like clone
people or anything which is what he did
with Jean Grey
he made Madeline Pryor but uh but the
fact remains you know they're like
basically you're gonna be the database
management for the entirety of the x-men
population or at least the mutant
population and where this version of
sinister basically shuts it down it says
why would I want to work with any of you
here on this particular thing he's
basically killed from behind and were
met with the real Nathaniel Essex now
this is kind of like a big change in
terms of Nathaniel Essex as we know him
because he's kinda pick today is well
there's really no better way to say it
um he's sassy basically what he is you
know like it's me mr. sinister it's kind
of what it seems like you know and I
think it's kind of cool actually I think
it's kind of interesting but it's a
pretty cool thing because what this does
is this sets the stage that where we
previously looked at all the x-men
stories that came before powers and
house of X and we saw mr. sinister as a
guy who was collecting the DNA of
mutants by using subterfuge right like
doing in a very very sneaky way and a
very underhanded way basically doing
what he was not supposed to do what
we're finding out here is that Xavier
basically sent him on that path and then
this is all been happening at the hands
of Xavier which is again a pretty cool
concept and so what this does is this
switches over to - Doug Ramsey and it
switches over to Xavier and basically
Xavier kind of again setting in motion
all the things that are going on right
now with the establishment of kharkova
as being a mutant Haven now up until
this point um and this is kind of an
interesting thing here because when when
this happens and we basically get you
know few a few months ago when we speed
up - what's basically a few months
before the events of the
they picked up with regards to house and
powers of X we end up finding that
Xavier traveled back to kokoa now krakoa
ahead had always kind of been in enemy
island more or less of the x-men and so
far that it was a it was a giant-size
x-men story right like this story where
they all kind of came together and they
had to save the x-men from cacoa and all
I kind of get stuck one of the cool
things that hickman does about this is
he actually says it's not really what we
think it is right in the sense that cook
halwa is there but it's not really a
malevolent island it's not an evil place
it's an island that's there and it never
Li had any true contact or at least in
its present form never Lee seem to have
any true contact with beings that were
out there and was really more curious
than anything else and so what he
basically does is he brings Seifer along
for the purpose of being able to
understand krakoa
and the reason why this matters is
because where Xavier can tap into Pecola
and Xavier can understand the more
empathetic tendencies right in the sense
of Walker Co is feeling and and how it's
perceiving things Doug Ramsey again as a
mutant that can basically speak any
language can essentially understand the
language of Garko at as it talks and
then turn it and yell created an
alphabet more or less and then pass that
on in in the form of Xavier absorbing it
and then setting it up so everybody
could understand that's really kind of
how all that worked but basically the
way this played out is in the modern day
the various x-men who want to escape
human persecution more or less who want
to go to a safe place will go to for
Cola but the question was always asked
if croco is speaks a language that
nobody on earth understands but how do
they understand it this is where that
begins that is Douglas Ramsey sitting
down is Douglas Ramsey learning to
understand the language having a full-on
conversation spending about a year here
to really grasp how it is deck work how
it talks you know it's like learning
French or Spanish or something like that
and then in turn what Xavier does is he
takes that information and he copies it
out of the mind of Doug Ramsey and then
from there the various telepaths is
stationed around Kirk OA install that
language for lack of a better word into
the mind of New Mutants so they
understand exactly what it is - Kirk oh
is saying and how the island functions
is a pretty cool thing here now from
there it jumps into the origin of krakoa
itself in terms of what Kirk OA was
before it became the landmass that it is
now but what we're told here is that at
some point in the past there was some
way just a land called Oak Hara and the
way it's described here by Hickman is a
little interesting but also a little
strange at the same time right because
this land is described as being ancient
before the word existed but not old in
the way that you know that
that they roll that like though the
world itself is old meaning that this
island existed but like either it was
artificially created or it rose up
somewhere along the line I would say
this chunk of landmass probably rose up
sometime during the great Cataclysm
right when the Celestra showed up during
the second host they wiped out most of
the deviants they sunk Atlantis that
somehow this popped up in the process
right it's a really real way to make it
make sense and the reason why that why I
say that is because somewhere along the
line this landmass of a car was split in
half and it became arauco and krakoa
and from this giant rift more or less
between these two chunks of land came
these massive demons right this Twilight
sword basically came with them now the
Twilight sword is interesting because on
one hand it kind of looks like the
all-black necro sword but it's not so we
know this is not know the god word I'm
not sorry I know the the symbiotes God
right and then my thought was well if
it's being called a Twilight sword then
maybe you're such my light sort of
Surtur
the issue is that the twilight sort of
Surtur looks a little bit different the
reality here is we're not given an
explicit explanation what these guys are
all we're told is that these demons
these monsters more or less showed up
out of this rift and then ultimately
they were fought by apocalypse and this
is why I say this takes place probably
somewhere around for 4,000 to 4,500
years ago right because apocalypse was
born five thousand years before the
modern day a didn't rise to prominence
until around maybe a hundred years after
that after everything that took place in
Egypt right so maybe around forty nine
hundred years ago is when this may or
may not take place right so we've got an
almost 5000 year window between when
this happened right so if we scale it
down and go by what we're being told
maybe anywhere between four - I'm sorry
five to four thousand years before the
modern day but regardless it took place
a long time ago and we don't really know
what these beings are and in fact all
we're really told here is that by virtue
of apocalypse defeating these forces and
then casting them back down into the
cavern and then cutting off that entire
section of core color from itself the
kirko has kind of been half an island
ever since and it always will be forever
right it's not it doesn't really seem to
be super important at the moment but
that's the nature of Jonathan Hickman
writing he gives you something that
seems pretty innocuous right it's just a
thing that's there and then suddenly it
becomes super important in like 20
issues right so that's one of these
reasons why when you're going out and
buying and you're reading these stories
you have to pay attention to everything
ultimately what is up happening here is
is Douglas Ramsey staves on it stays on
Unger Cola for about a year and then
basically goes to the process of
understanding how it all works and so
what we do to this point is we jump to
the future and we talk about this
concept of of basically ascension now
remember from what we saw in the last
the last issue ascension is basically
like this sort of final step for those
individuals who are essentially robots
right like the idea is that when a
robots created you know with a baseline
Sentinel is really where hickman starts
from you go from a baseline Sentinel
which is given a command and the command
is basically eliminate mutants now it
follows that command to the best of its
ability and is given a little bit of
leeway there right in so far it's like a
signal would look at a mutant say okay
mutants are the enemy
but mutants stem from humans because of
the next step in human evolution
therefore all mutants have the potential
to become mutants and so all humans are
enemies like that's the kind of
conclusion that a that a sentinel would
draw right but only insofar as the
command that it's given right it
wouldn't say like your job is to take
care of like all all mutants like a a
signal wouldn't look at that in
extrapolate and say okay because there's
there's humans then there's humanoids we
should also take out humanoids no it's
confined to that line of programming
beyond that you go into master mode
which is given a little bit more of
leeway in terms of sentinels in terms of
how it creates them as well as like
getting up and leaving and going to a
safe place if it's in danger but it's
still continually following the program
of my job is to create sentinels then
you go into a mother mold which is a
little more intelligent then you go into
a Nimrod which is artificial
intelligence and then you go into what
are basically humans that are bonded
with nanites and become like the perfect
sort of signal but the issue with this
and this is one of the things that
higgling kind of points out here is that
this is Sinden see that's currently
taking place right now this landscape in
you know a thousand years in the future
what we found out in the last video is
that these aren't humans and they're not
mutants that humans and mutants have
essentially been wiped out or pushed to
the brink of extinction mutants for the
most part seem to be gone almost
entirely what's left of them
exists way out there in the far reaches
of space as part of the Shiar empire
those who were left on earth and there's
there's probably around eight or nine of
them they're the only ones really left
in this part of the universe from there
you you you basically look at humans and
what we were told here is that humans
kind of exist in small little
encampments but they're more fleeing for
their lives and try not to be caught
that what you have now basically running
the show are these human and and robot
hybrids right these these sort of
perfect beans these Omega sentinels more
or less is what they're called that
exists out there the issue
running into here is that when the
Phalanx show up and they're trying to
reach a sinden see the goal of the
Phalanx is to basically look around at
all machine concepts right like all
robots who have achieved a higher level
of utter artificial intelligence they
basically allows them to transcend their
programming and even transcend humanity
right to think far beyond the means of a
normal human but to also somewhat
function as humans and then absorb them
into themselves if they're far enough
along if they're of interest right
that's basically what it is the issue
with this is that they're not fully
robotic and so one of the ways they're
trying to get around that and it's kind
of with us this comic ends one of the
ways you're trying to get around that is
we're actually trying to essentially
take their consciousness and then put it
inside a computer shell and then when
that's done the Phalanx will see that
computer shell and then say ok like we
will absorb that because as far as the
Phalanx are aware this is a being that's
achieved I guess a machine has achieved
a higher level of thinking that really
seems to be what's going on here but
again this is classic hickman right you
get this a little bit of information and
then it's done and that's that's
basically it and then it wraps up and
it's a cool little moment here because
the question is are beings actually
going to achieve a higher level of
ascension is this really the fate of
humanity that humans and mutants are
socially gonna be wiped out and they're
gonna be replaced by robot biological
being hybrid this is kind of an
important thing here because if you go
back and you look at Hickman's Avengers
and New Avengers and I know I keep
saying that everything from is fantastic
for although I've been till now is all
one giant cohesive story right and so
when you look at that you say ok you
have the the the portion of the story
where Captain America and Black Widow
and Hawkeye and I think somebody else I
came over get flung into the future and
along the way they basically start
dropping off but you get 50,000 years
into the future and you basically end up
realizing that like the Avengers
transcend the earth and become this
Universal Protection Force right so like
there's a future there but how do you
get from point A to point B and will
that future come to fruition that's
really the what's being presented to us
here by Jonathan Hickman and that's
really the question that we have to ask
but without being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you guys
are new here to come this explain it
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the robb core if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later purse
[Music]
[Music]